all right everybody buckle in these next
two segments are pretty pretty full on
nuts over the weekend donald trump spoke
at another one of these right-wing
events of no consequence this particular
event was in austin texas now we had a
correspondent on the ground
talking to trumpists and we're going to
get to those videos in a moment but
first what did donald trump say this is
maybe
the most callous
moment
of donald trump's political career now i
know he made fun of the disabled
reporter
and yelled out where's my
african-american he's had all these
cringe moments but this is wacky trump
going on stage and saying
i think they had a tragic event in
buffalo referring to the mass shooter
who targeted black people killing ten
injuring three
and somehow
transitions into bragging that nobody
died in afghanistan while he was
president
it's a bizarre and disturbing political
moment take a look at this
we didn't lose one
american soldier think of it
not one
as opposed to last night
which you saw in milwaukee and you saw
i guess a total of 20 in different and
just as i'm coming off the stage i think
they had a tragic event in buffalo
just as i'm coming on the stage tragic
event in buffalo with
numerous people being killed in 18
months in afghanistan we lost nobody i
spoke with what what is the connection
between those two things
it's outrageous
that in the same sentence as domestic
gun violence
he's talking about afghanistan this
shooting in buffalo didn't happen thanks
to biden i mean is that what he's
suggesting that listen when i was
president nobody died in afghanistan but
there was a mass shooting in milwaukee
and a mass shooting
in buffalo
and i'm no longer president but biden is
like is that the implication
and in fact this is particularly
egregious it's particularly disgusting
because the right wing rhetoric cited in
the alleged manifesto of the buffalo
shooter
is exactly the type of stuff
that coalesced around trump and that was
fomented by right-wing media when donald
trump became president of the united
states it's
an outrageous comparison to make trump
also at one point said something really
weird
about elon musk saying musk has problems
and maybe trump's social media platform
is better and he again doesn't say it
correctly you guys know how trump
glitches all the time and he recently
got the name of his own platform
incorrect truth essential truth sensual
yeah he again botched it it's very weird
see if you can understand this it's hot
and it's actually much much better than
twitter it's so it blows twitter away
everybody loves it especially the
engagement i mean it's amazing elon musk
so
i don't believe he's going to buy
twitter because you have so many fake
accounts the bots
all of the different things i think it's
going to be very interesting and he's
got some problems because he bought a
lot of stock that he shouldn't have
bought you've got a lot of problems with
twitter but the twitter has a lot of
problems so go to truth truth social i
think you're going to find
truth essential
yeah so i guess he's making the point
that truth essential is better than
twitter and maybe even better than truth
social and then lastly trump says he's
writing a book called the crime of the
century about how i guess the election
was stolen from him kind of getting sad
at this point anything about it they go
after other people
they don't want to go after criminals
that kill people on the streets they go
after others they go aft they like going
after republicans that's what they
really like this is the greatest this is
the crime of the century i'm actually
writing a book about called the crime of
the century i don't think you'll enjoy
it you'll be very depressed when you're
well i i just don't believe trump's
writing anything trump doesn't read and
trump doesn't write so none of it is
making sense to me so a completely
depraved event trump doesn't know up
from down day from night left is right
unclear what's going on but he continues
to be completely unempathetic in every
way to everything going on in the world
and next let's go to our interviews with
some of his supporters
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description